[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
guten abend und willkommen ihnen allen
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
sport guten abend und das sind die
themen von heute
runde mit dem gasverbrauch
wirtschaftsminister habe ich will unter
anderem mehr strom aus kohlekraftwerken
klar bei der afg nach einem heftigen
streit über die europa und russland
politik wird der parteitag in riesa
vorzeitig beendet und
flucht vor dem waldbrand in brandenburg
müssen hunderte ihre häuser verlassen
der landrat den katastrophenfall aus
es passt nicht recht zur hitze des tages
dass wir uns mit frieren im winter
beschäftigen müssen doch die
gedrosselten gaslieferungen aus russland
bringen deutschland in bedrängnis die
lage sei ernst sagt der
wirtschaftsminister und präsentiert neue
maßnahmen um die versorgung zu sichern
aktuell sind die gasspeicher in
deutschland zu knapp 57 prozent gefüllt
bis zum ersten november sollen es 90
prozent werden das allein wird aber wohl
nicht ausreichen um durch den winter zu
kommen was jetzt helfen soll zeigt
alexandra vacano
statt gas mehr kohlekraftwerke
sie sollen jetzt wieder mehr strom
produzieren bitter für den grünen
wirtschaftsminister doch die ernste lage
erfordere ernste schritte so habeck
heute das entsprechende gesetz dazu soll
schon im juli in kraft treten das sind
dann im wesentlichen
steinkohlekraftwerke die haben eine
höhere co2 emission als gaskraftwerke
das ist kein schritt der mir leicht
fällt aber ein notwendiger schritt er
jetzt gegangen wird jetzt müsse mehr gas
in die speicher sie können gas mit einem
energiegehalt von rund 256
terawattstunden speichern das reicht für
zwei bis drei wintermonate insgesamt
wird jährlich erdgas von rund 1000
terawattstunden verbraucht deshalb gibt
es auch 15 milliarden euro vom bund für
netzbetreiber um gas einzukaufen und die
befüllung der speicher voranzutreiben
und für die industrie ein gas
auktionsmodell es soll den unternehmen
anreize bieten gas einzusparen um es
dann am markt zu verkaufen
die industrie ein schlüsselfaktor so
habeck inzwischen arbeiten unternehmen
an der gas einsparung machen sich sorgen
vor leeren speichern weil dann die
produktion stillstehen könnte die stadt
speicher voll machen müssen wir müssen
gleichzeitig versuchen möglichst viele
andere quellen aufzutun wir werden
umstellen müssen das ist auch etwas was
schnell geschehen muss dort wo es zb mit
öl geht woher jetzt noch energie
gewinnen fracking also erdgasförderung
heißt es aus der fdp aus umweltgründen
eigentlich seit 2017 verboten an land
sollten wir uns überlegen ob wir nicht
in sicheren umgebungen durch sogenannte
schiefergas förderung auch eigene
potenziale erschließen denn zur wahrheit
gehört dazu wir importieren im moment
das schiefergas aber wir fördern es
nicht selbst ist wäre ökologisch
vorteilhaft es selbst zu fördern und
fracking hier ein klares nein von
bundeswirtschaftsminister
die debatte um die gasversorgung sie
läuft heiß auch wenn der winter noch in
weiter ferne scheint
mehr dazu gleich nach uns in berlin
direkt
bei der afg brach am nachmittag ihren
parteitag ab nach einem erbitterten
streit über eine europafeindliche
resolution schon zuvor hatten sich die
beiden erst gestern zur neuen
führungsspitze gewählten tino copala und
alles weil mehrfach nicht durchsetzen
können christiane hübsche hat mehr
vorzeitiger abbruch um noch schlimmeres
zu verhindern dabei sollte es heute
endlich mal um inhalte gehen doch schon
am morgen ein gespaltener parteitag
einen antrag kommt durch der es künftig
erlaubt auch organisationen mit
kontakten zu rechtsextremisten in die ft
aufzunehmen die unterlegenen entsetzt
wir wollen uns allen ernstes hier in
verbindung gegeben mit solchen leuten
die jetzt auch noch mit npd neue werte
und so weiter auf die straße gehen
machen wir doch nicht so einen unsinn
die anhänger unterstützt den antrag und
lässt die maske fallen führt den neuen
bundesvorstand die mir gestern er in
some teils regelrecht vor deswegen
bestimmen wir qua unserer eigenen kraft
unseres eigenen selbstbewusstseins
unseres eigenen willens wer
extremistisch und von wem wir uns
abgrenzen dann die eskalation als es um
eine europafeindliche resolution geht
über zwei stunden lang versuchen die
neuen parteichefs copala und weil die
abstimmung zu verschieben und scheitern
immer wieder
dieses papier muss jetzt zur abstimmung
kommen bitte wir schreien uns nicht an
also ich beantrage ende dieses parteitag
ist dass es unwürdig und wir debattieren
uns hier gerade ich möchte keine
resolution hier verabschiedet wissen die
mit 55 prozent durchgehen europa braucht
am ende rückendeckung mehrerer
landeschefs um sich doch noch
durchzusetzen tag 1 der neu gewählten
parteiführung und sie ist bereits schwer
beschädigt tja nicole diekmann im
sächsischen riesa kein guter start für
die neue fdp spitze
ja das kann man ganz klar so sagen das
neue duo an der parteispitze gerade mal
24 stunden im amt muss schon jetzt eine
reihe schwerer niederlagen verbuchen
alice weile und tino kubala wurden hier
in riesa vor großem publikum von
rechtsextremisten blöcke regelrecht
vorgeführt türke hatte in den ersten
beiden tagen dieses parteitages
durchblicken lassen die mächtig ist und
heute hat er das sehr unverblümt
demonstriert der ersehnte und verkündete
neuanfang endlich als geeinte afd der
ist krachend gescheitert was von diesen
drei tagen hier in riesa bleibt das ist
vielmehr der eindruck von chaos und von
einer nach wie vor heillos zerstrittenen
partei mit einer ganz frischen und
dennoch bereits beschädigten führung die
schon jetzt mehrere machtkämpfe gegen
hacker und sein lager verloren hat klare
worte von nicole diekmann findern
in frankreich läuft noch bis 20 uhr die
zweite runde der parlamentswahl es geht
um 572 sitze der nationalversammlung die
bei der ersten runde noch nicht vergeben
wurden das parteienbündnis hinter
präsident marco könnte nach jüngsten
umfragen seine absolute mehrheit
verlieren vor einer woche lag das neue
grüne bündnis unter führung von makros
konkurrent meldung schon fast gleichauf
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg rechnet
damit dass der krieg in der ukraine
jahre lang dauern könnte deshalb dürfe
die unterstützung für das land nicht
nachlassen sagte er der bild am sonntag
russische angriffe gab es wieder nahe
der stadt micro laut örtlichen behörden
wurde ein treibstofflager getroffen
schwer umkämpft bleibt die region
luhansk dort meldet die ukraine erneut
heftigen beschuss
zurück nach deutschland es ist eine
fatale mischung aus hitze wind und
trockenheit seit freitag gerät ein
waldbrand in brandenburg immer wieder
außer kontrolle heute mussten mehrere
ortsteile evakuiert werden das
waldgebiet ist etwa 40 kilometer von
potsdam entfernt nahe der kleinstadt
treuenbrietzen und auch bei beelitz
brennt es katrin lindner ist für uns in
treuenbrietzen den dritten tag geht das
nun schon so die flammen fressen sich
immer weiter über 650 einsatzkräfte sind
inzwischen vor ort nach wie vor ist es
schwierig den brand in dem munition
belasteten gebiet zu löschen doch erst
seit gestern abend gibt es unterstützung
der bundeswehr aus der luft ich stehe
hier am rand des brandgebietes und man
kann sehen wie stark der wind weht doch
gerade der wind ist das was sie hier so
fürchten die stärke des windes und die
richtung aus sicherheitsgründen wurden
mehrere ortsteile evakuiert über 600
menschen mussten ihre häuser verlassen
inzwischen haben die länder sachsen
anhalt und berlin ihre unterstützung
zugesagt
die größte gefahr ist tatsächlich dass
wir jetzt im hochwald sind und der wind
nicht nachlässt wie sehr wir haben die
große hoffnung dass es irgendwann die
nachtstunden möglicherweise anfängt zu
regnen das könnte uns helfen doch dieser
waldbrand ist längst nicht der einzige
in der region nur wenige kilometer
weiter ist ein feuer bei beelitz seit
dem nachmittag außer kontrolle
wir hoffen auf regen jetzt bist du dran
mit dem alten und neuen deutschen
meister im basketball der männer die
pleite vorgestern hat alba berlin nicht
aus der bahn geworfen mit dem dritten
sieg im vierten spiel gegen bayern
münchen deutlich mit 96 280 holen sich
die berliner in bayerns hauptstadt
wieder den nationalen titel und schaffen
dabei obendrein schon zum sechsten mal
das double aus meisterschaft und
pokalsieg
schon in den letzten beiden jahren haben
die berliner den meisterpokal in münchen
überreicht bekommen zwei tage nach der
saftigen heim niederlage im dritten
spiel der finalserie dominieren die
gelben die partie diesmal von beginn an
janine smith erzielte 23 punkte der
topscorer der partie bayerns
basketballer müssen sich erneut
geschlagen geben für alba berlin ist es
der elfte meistertitel
sind ja tillmann und svenja müller haben
bei der beachvolleyball-wm in rom bronze
gewonnen das gegnerische team aus der
schweiz musste im zweiten satz aufgeben
weil sich joana heidrich bei einem
aufschlag die schulter ausgekugelt hatte
gleich zweimal bronze in der
rhythmischen sportgymnastik und damit
die ersten em medaillen für deutschland
seit 42 jahren gewinnt die erst 15 jahre
alte dara war follow me in tel aviv sie
wird dritter in den final wettkämpfen
mit dem ball und mit den keulen und das
tennisturnier auf gras in halle in
westfalen gewinnt überraschend der pole
hubert homepage klar in zwei sätzen
gegen daniel mit wieder der aus russland
das hatte sich daniel medwedew sicher
ganz anders vorgestellt
gegen den polen hubert uhr kath war der
russische weltranglisten-erste 62
minuten lang völlig chancenlos ohne eine
einzige breakmöglichkeit
unterlag der nummer zwölf der welt glatt
in zwei sätzen
eine bessere entscheidung hätte sich
burkhard für den saisonhöhepunkt in
einer woche in wimbledon kaum ausstellen
können
passen pokal ja hübsch
weniger hitze aber mehr unwetter
erwarten uns morgen im nordosten und in
der mitte schauer und gewitter sonst
wolkig oder sonnig im süden am
nachmittag einzelne kräftige gewitter
höchsttemperatur 17 bis 24 grad im süden
bis 33 grad
christian sievers begrüßt sie im heute
journal um 21 uhr 45 morgen übernimmt
hier mitri sirin wir sagen tschüss danke
fürs zuschauen und geben weiter an
berlin direkt und theo koll